by the end of 2003 Cox has done 90
fraudulent real estate deals 90 totaling
almost four million dollars by the end
of 2003 you had done that much the in
number it was see the number is always
shifting they said so hundred and
hundred and nine transactions is what
they be I even said that I did and they
said I borrowed 11.5 million dollars now
he's saying what do you say four million
mm-hmm but at the st. Petersburg Times
gap Testament is about to go to print
with a major expose of toxicity Cox
catches wind that he's about to be
front-page news and Matt knew that if
this came out it was all gonna come down
on him I would do that I would take a
bunch of money in line man says I gotta
get out of here I got to leave you know
you want to count
Rebeca Hawk has known Matt Cox for just
six weeks incredibly she puts a 13
year-old son Brice on a plane to her
mom's house says goodbye to him and
hello to life as a fugitive it was it
was so hard and I was crying
hysterically embrace this like mom
you'll see me in two weeks and Matt's
standing there and I'm crying I'm not
standing there I'm not there at all yeah
when Bryce got on the plane
Matt's like you'll see him it'll be okay
you're gonna be able to see him as much
as you want never for you this gown I
never said that
how dare you [ __ ] [ __ ] complete
[ __ ] listen listen this chick she's
[ __ ] chicken man
listen when she gets arrested you know
what she said about me when they first
arrested her and immediately interviewed
her but you know remember I told you she
suck and says she's not Rebecca Hulk she
was on my name is Rebecca Hickey you had
the wrong name you're the wrong are you
the wrong person you guys are good she
they end up putting her hand on the
thing she felt like 45 minutes or an
hour she like denies it till they
finally put her hand out on the scanner
and this she's like all right it's me so
her first interview with me we're about
me was Cox's meek
he's charismatic he's he's shy he's not
he's not the kind of person that he's
not aggressive he's I mean she basically
paints me as a guy that's just not going
to is not a an aggressive type person or
a person that's that's whatever
mean-spirited whatever you want to say
yeah then she gets this lawyer with the
Johnnie Cochran law firm and it becomes
he's abusive he's manipulative he forced
me to leave my son he forced me to get a
boob job he forced me to be out of your
[ __ ] mind
I knew you a month you should we had a
date on like a [ __ ] Thursday night or
a Friday night I'm throwing my [ __ ] this
is when I find out that the police were
cut that they f that I'm gonna be
arrested by the FBI within the next few
days
I'm throwing my stuff into duffel bags
she's been calling me all all all day
about our date I'm not answering she
walks in my apartment or might caught my
um my house as I'm throwing [ __ ] in I'm
like hey what's up and she's like you
were our returning calls what are you
doing and I was like [ __ ] we got a date
I was like listen uh bad news it's
coming to arrest me I'm out of here
and she says wait what are you doing you
can't leave I love you I want to come
with you we had this whole argument
about her son I'm like what are you
talking about you got a [ __ ] kid you
you can't [ __ ] believe it I'm going
on the run right now you can't come with
me and she's like no you don't
understand he's going back he was going
back to live with his father he
basically lived with his father most of
his life she brought him with from from
Vegas brought him with her she brought
him with her yeah from Vegas he'd been
picked up twice for like a app being
around out after it like snuck out of
her house after curfew he got caught
smoking pot he was failing all of his
grades she's like I can't handle him
he's too much he's I'm sending him back
to live with his father anyway she's
like you know she's like look he's going
anyway back with his father and I said
look you know understand I said you're
not gonna see this [ __ ] kid again I
said even if you see him it'll be for a
couple hours and it'll be
random if you see him at all and she's
like I don't care I want the money if I
can see him every once in a while that's
fine at least I can give him some money
at least you know you know so she's just
[ __ ] begging to come with me follows
me around for two or three days won't
leave me alone and looking back on it
the truth is I could have just [ __ ]
left her you know but she was like
really worried about it really on me and
the truth of matter it was a major
mistake to let her come with me but at
the moment I was terrified and I was
leaving everybody I knew and everything
I knew behind and that that's a huge
[ __ ] step to make for sure and so you
know and so I finally just towards like
the last day I said okay look you can
come with me you know and looking back
on it's like you should I should have
done this I should have 20/20 hindsight
you know it is it was just a major
mistake bringing her with me major
[ __ ] mistake and you know and I
really should have just left her and and
and for more than the reasons that she
ended up just being this bipolar maniac
other than just that it was also cuz of
her son I should have made the decision
for her I should have but the truth is
I'm going off on the run I'm terrified
but I didn't have to be alone and that's
a big thing about going off you're
leaving everybody behind and everything
you know behind and you're alone yeah so
it's like it would be easier with her
there and so I said alright you can come
but I certainly didn't convince her to
come or try and get her to come or ask
her to come or ask her leave her kids
because then it turned into he's abusive
he's manipulative he made me get a boob
job I mean are you out of your [ __ ]
mind
a boob guy sure boobs were fine okay
it's just you know and then they then
they focus it on the whole single mother
single mother they don't mention Jana
Jana wasn't single I mean she she didn't
have any kids you know I dated tons of
women didn't have kit didn't have any
kids they always see you gotta
practically cut this out because I get
so [ __ ] angry about the whole [ __ ]
thing it's just even Shaunie it's like
our law firm I mean you were so funny is
like normally I'm very
about the old thing like you know it was
my fault that I'm apologetic and I do
the whole thing but this this this it's
like being just blatantly lied about it
just infuriates me
yeah just and it's just you know you
know and what's so funny is that you
know I've talked to her since I've been
out right you know and she's like so
like how did that conversation go it
actually she ended up meeting some guy
in the halfway house they got married
she's got another kid she's very nice
she's a nice person like now and even
she says I'm like you were a [ __ ]
maniac and she's like I was going
through something okay she's like it was
a bad time for me she's a much better
now I just had I even told her look okay
and I was we were talking about that she
told me her I tell you this she told me
her lawyer showed up drunk for her at
her sentencing oh really
yeah she goes she said you know and Gail
McKenzie and and she's talking about the
US Attorney she's [ __ ] said this and
this and everybody was pushing me to say
this and say that matches you understand
I was trying to get my sentence reduced
to no I understand I said but you know
the problem is now I have to live with
it I said so
she is well I'm sorry I wish I could do
something if I could do something I
would I go you could you could go on the
podcast with me I said you could go on a
podcast with me and say what really
happens you know she's I can't do that
why she said because I've been telling
my mother and my my husband the story
she said for the last 12 years or ten
years just know I I can't change now he
doesn't see this podcast so and I told
her listen I I haven't asked her once
bro I've asked her like five [ __ ]
times I'm like I'm telling you didn't
tell your husband go to your husband you
have a good relationship oh my god he's
the best he's amazing he's a great guy
he's great great it's a great guy then
he'll understand
the situation you were in and you just
ran with it because you didn't want to
own up to the fact that you made some
bad [ __ ] decisions hmm so say those
guys out now and I want to clear the air
and I'll feel so much better about
myself I'll feel better about the
situation I want to do the right thing
shows no no no no no she ain't come when
she is I'm not gonna do that
mm-hmm she said look I I can't do that I
said okay so well I said you understand
I said at some point if somebody asked
me I'm
[ __ ] say it she is no I understand me
hell she's never gonna meet you she's
like as though she said I understand so
we'll see what she says if I ever talk
to her again
Wow okay a few days later on December
14th 2003 Testament series dubious deals
hits the newsstands the reporter details
of fraud worth more than four million
dollars but Matt Cox is gone he was
never seen in Tampa again ever
the trail went cold for me for a while
where Cox was like I didn't know the
people who know him best assume he's
fled the country they think he's gotten
on the cruise ship and he's headed to
some Island South Cox's ex-girlfriend
Alison Arnold is among those asking
questions
I always wondered you know what happened
Alison has not been caught for her role
where did they get those photos of you
those photos we're like the Superman
sure and some computer well I know the
one chick next to me was on your myspace
on myspace was that not around o3 I
think that myspace was around I mean I
was it when was myspace around I don't
know I know this chick I met named
MySpace started this 2003 2003
yeah 2003 well I wasn't on it okay no I
would say that's probably Alison Arnold
and probably Jana because the one chick
in the picture where I have a Superman
thing and she has one that's Jana okay
one of Cox's scams six months earlier
she poses as Rosita Perez and takes out
fraudulent home loans
though the police have not yet come
knocking on her door allison is worried
she knows the Heat's on I was a nervous
wreck
I got a job as a waitress because I
couldn't work for any bank my hands
would shake my conscious was so heavy
Allison decides to call the FBI
so I spilled my guts out said everything
Allison tells the feds everything she
knows to help them catch Cox Allison
thinks her cooperation will buy her
immunity from prosecution wrong
eventually she sentenced to two years in
prison for bank fraud you want to hear
this there's like 14 or 15 people on the
indictment right so they've all been
indicted mm-hmm but the FBI doesn't do
anything they're waiting to catch me
I've talked to a bunch of people
everybody's going in and say Matt did
this math did that some people are going
to say no so and so did this so and so
did this so they're saying no I didn't
do that so and so everybody's pointing
but they've got they understand
everybody who's involved because by the
time they talked to me they're they've
walk in with a stack of [ __ ] 302 boom
they're like I mean you're done mm-hmm
so which I know I'm done anyway so the
point is is that they haven't they
haven't investigated even arrested
anybody you've known about this for six
months or so you haven't got anything
why aren't you arresting they're waiting
to catch me because they figure we'll
catch Cox we'll catch that the top dog
he'll just explain everything that
happened will crack everybody in the
head it'll be fine right they don't
expect that I'm gonna be missing so long
Allison is riddled with guilt mm-hmm and
she Rob fear she's like [ __ ] they're
gonna come arrest me someday right so
she goes into the FBI and says I just
want to tell you what happened get
charged be sentenced and be done with it
I'll cooperate against everybody she
initially when she talked to him she
thinks she is thinking I won't go to
jail I'll do probation at the most and
I'll cooperate so she goes in she
cooperates she agrees to plead guilty
turns herself in I'm sorry nobody else
does
guess who the only person that ends up
like on that indictment that ends up
going to prison is the only person that
owns up to everything they did
cooperates against everyone straight to
[ __ ] prison you don't get [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you go to prison that's what they
[ __ ] did everybody else on the
indictment no half them people are still
working in banking Wow now in that I
mean I don't want to say hilarious but
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up because you
know the least that the the least
culpable person in my entire indictment
is Allyson Arnold she walked into one
bank two closings didn't make a [ __ ]
I think maybe I gave her felt I gave her
like ten grand for doing it like hey
look you know we really didn't really
make any money but here's like ten grand
or something and I had been giving her
money and she's closing loans she's
doing okay but we didn't make any money
so where's their money to give you
there's nothing to give you what about
the blonde girl how much time did she
give Oh
Becky Becky Becky wasn't a part of this
conspiracy she's a part of the next
conspiracy when I take off on the run so
she's not even on my indictment oh [ __ ]
okay right the only other person that
goes to jail is is Eric tamargo but he
goes to jail not because of the
indictment he goes to jail because he's
already on federal probation and he
fails a [ __ ] piss test and because
he's on this other indictment they go
ahead and they violate his probation and
give him like 30 months or something he
goes to Coleman he does the drug program
so I mean she's the only one on the
indictment that goes to prison for the
indictment he goes to one on a violation
she because she felt bad Josie you
watching guilty conscience I mean it's
just the nicest person you know so [ __ ]
half the sentence for somebody who had
no previous criminal records really I
had no knowledge of everything that I
was totally doing but I followed along
and did something yes that I know was
illegal yes you know everybody knows
that right and wrong inside but I just
I don't think the consequences would be
like this while Alison faces prison Matt
Cox and Rebecca Hart head to Atlanta
when American greed returns Matt Cox
lives out a real-life game of catch me
if you can that's true
[Laughter]